now christopher wondering when he had
seconds left on the clock and here we go
and here we go and uh after duda pushed
his e pawn forward push the king's pawn
forward it's ivanka's favorite opening
again but this time magnus is on the
black side of the karakan you're happy
to see this on your banker of course i'm
absolutely delighted uh this is what i
dream about and okay in here we have the
fantasy variation it's one of the
sharpest lines there is against the
karakan and white's idea is very simple
just protecting the center with a pawn
and magnus goes for a very safe approach
which is to reinforce the center it will
just develop his pieces and at the right
time break forward with a timely c6 c5
yeah so uh fantasy variation i never
knew how to handle it until recently it
was just uh every time i play online
blitz it comes up and i was just
freestyling it's a really flexible
opening for both sides a variation at
least of the carrycon and uh okay magnus
he's offering a transposition into the
french defense it started as a carican
and it would become the french defense
if white pushes his central pawn forward
as he has done white's now gonna
continue trying to build space over the
next few moves uh duda first though
retreating the white knight just so you
can kind of build this pawn chain very
sensible and uh is this how you handle
the kara khan no because i don't play
the french defense so i i can't handle
the fantasy in this way no i instead i
prefer to develop the dark square bishop
out and put the pressure on the center
that way and uh
okay but this is something that magnus
is familiar with
and we've seen him employ the french
defense
i'm thinking about his game against
harry krishna
uh in day think day two or day one of
the preliminaries yeah so magnus has won
with the french defense before that was
actually a crazy game where magnus
sacrificed a piece of peace for few
pawns just to explode up in the center
this is very different of course but
then again black is the first to castle
black is much better developed than
white but look at this white pawns are
storming forward white is going to kind
of initiate a dark square strategy put
all his pawns on dart squares and he's
just going to try and hope that the
black pieces can't break out from their
cage black's pieces do lack space they
do fight for the same squares that's why
magnus is now trying to open up lines
maybe for his rooks this could backfire
though if white is accurate if white's
pieces get into the game but look at
this all of white spawns now apart from
one on dark squares it's clear what duda
is going for with the strategy it's up
to magnus to try and break out and fight
especially against the head of white's
pawn chain in the center but first he
switches
attention and just pushes pawns the
white knight though developing
unleashing the white light squared
bishop
i'm i've got to say despite what the
evaluation bar says
black has to be really careful here i
love white's chances if white gets one
more move if white's light squared
bishop can develop d3 square point
towards the black king white already has
already made attack magnus has to be
careful now
and uh he puts pressure on white's
center the question is
can white go all in and sacrifice a porn
and he is going for it now you have to
be a bit careful if you're black you
can't actually grab the pawn that's uh
up for sale because after all the trades
have been amassed there will be a queen
sitting loosely on the d4 square and the
bishop can come and
take a pawn on h7 okay right we're going
to see it wow
ivanka there's actually a big
opportunity here and duda is calculating
it white has i'm not sure whether it
works but white has the option of what
we call a greek gift sacrifice uh it's a
great gift because you give up white's
bishop white's light square bishop you
can actually go and take a pawn near the
black king luring out the black king out
into the open and then you can throw
even more pieces on the fire you can
throw a knight forward with a check you
can bring the white queen into the
attack
do you think dude is going to go for
this is he just going to recapture this
pawn on your back as you said which is
fine for white white's pawn structure is
just about defensible
or do you just burn your bridges gamble
and open the position up sacrificing two
pieces to go for black skin yeah i did
see the greek sacrifice that you
mentioned where you sacrificed two
pieces to open up the h line
it's risky
it's a lot of pieces and you have to
calculate well he's done it he's gone
for it but he's gone for in a different
way yeah so not giving up the white
light squared bishop to lure out that
black king break it out into the open
instead trying to give up his knight oh
look at the bar
the computer hates this that means the
sacrifice simply doesn't work but in
order to accept the sacrifice you need
courage you need nerves of steel and uh
magnus if he takes this white knight it
looks like dude is just gifting him a
knight for free if the black pawn
captures this knight then suddenly white
will use his bishop and
open up the black king and look at the h
line that will open up if you take white
tonight white will recapture with the
pawn eventually uh gaining time and
are you obliged to capture that night no
that's the big thing for magnus if you
take this knight maybe you'll live to
tell the tale and you'll be a couple of
pieces up but look at the evaluation
part again magnus hasn't moved and it's
re-corrected itself ah that's how
complicated the position is even
computers need a deeper horizon they
need more time to crunch the numbers
crunch the moves in order to get to the
truth and
if you're sacrificing a piece maybe even
two and the evaluation bar still says
it's roughly balanced that means it's
quite promising from a practical
perspective so really interesting look
at the clock times as well dude going
for it he scared magnus magnus now down
to two minutes dude still with nearly
four minutes and magnus doesn't take the
piece no he doesn't take the piece but
we're still going to see fire on the
board because uh well duda has grabbed a
pawn in the center but look it's on the
same line as the black queen so does
this mean that black can kind of get
fruity and capture a pawn in the center
clearing the path
for the queen's attack against the
knight and he has played it okay he's
played a different avenue so clearing
the light square bishop black's light
square bishop hitting the white knight
in the center of the board now so kind
of a pseudo-sacrifice offering up your
piece but trying to go for white's piece
uh so the key here the critical
variation now is for white to actually
get greedy and capture the black rook
that white knight was doomed anyway so
you might as well grab a rook in the
process and black's knight in the center
trays itself off for a bishop so the
material count white has an extra rook
but black has a bishop and a pawn in
return and also black has an open king
to attack and that is very very scary
most french players um they
they dream about these kind of positions
and these sacrifices this is why they
play the french defense
so i
really am very very worried for duda's
position he has to get his king to
safety he has to control the activity of
black's minor pieces because look at it
he's taken a lot of risks with his pawn
structure there's holes all over the
place
yeah dude does not look comfortable he
is much happier as an attacker than a
defender and now he's forced on the
defensive and i actually gave lessons a
while ago to a 10 year old child and
that 10 year old child played the french
defense he said to me david
as in
in the french defense if you have a
light squared bishop that's blocked in
it's fine as soon as the bishop gets out
you win the game and that's happening
now magnus carlsen's light squared
bishop is about to come out on the
diagonal
and that piece is possibly going to win
the game for him dude shaking his head
this one's turned
i loved what duder did but it backfired
and magnus now giving up a rook not
everyone would have done that he's not
materialistic he's opened up the
position and now black's light squared
bishop is going to come out surely
and once it does there we go the black
bishop is out in the french defense you
nearly never see it this active this
piece
and suddenly the white king is under
heavy fire black's rook that rhino is
going to steam over into the center of
the board check that white king and duda
leaning back
is he giving up hope already it's really
dangerous now yeah white
we should mention it's not legal to
castle over to the queen side now to the
left side because that black bishop cuts
over and you can't castle through check
but if you cast on the other side notice
the black queen is on the same diagonal
as the white king there'll be a discover
check duda going on the counter attack
though hitting black's bishop this is
his last chance yeah but this does allow
the queen to dive in grab a pawn attack
the rook where's the rook going to move
i mean okay well okay attacks the queen
and uh well i suspect that the queen
okay we see a check first this is a nice
strategy and uh he's just winning ivanka
king the king can't move the white king
if it moves will lose its bishop and if
white queen takes this black rook then
black's queen takes the white rook
white's queen is overworked if it takes
the black rook it loses protection
of its own rook dude is about to lose
this game magnus
just overworking the white pieces and
white's king is doomed we talked about
dude's 26 move win magnus is winning in
21 moves here as black
this is impressive
yeah and uh it was all because of knight
dudes very committal night move and
there we see a few captures on the board
and it is looking dreadful for white and
look at white's king is defenseless
black now has three pieces two bishops
and a knight for two white rooks but
look at white's rook in the corner stuck
next to its king look how open the king
is on the diagonals dude knows he's done
this attack is going to be deadly he's
not going to survive that white king
it's living on borough time
i mean
all it needs is a dark square bishop to
come into the game and look it's game
over and uh now a knight is in
and there's is there a big threat in the
in the position yeah there's a couple of
big threats black's queen now is
threatened to come down to the bottom of
the board and that would end in disaster
for white look how white's queen is cut
off from the defense of her king that
black knight in the centre of the board
acting as a defender and an attacker
look at that smile on
the champion's face magnus carlsen wins
the charity cup in thai breaks after a
tough fight against young christophe
duda look at that it's nice to see that
smile probably a little bit tired but uh
impressive stuff by magnus carlson look
at that what is that smile about david a
smile